Agave is the succulent plant native to
Desert regions of Mexico and the source
of liquids rapidly growing in popularity
in this country tequila and mezcal were
the second fastest growing Spirits
category last year with sales climbing
30 percent from 2020 to 5.2 billion
dollars helping lead the change or
high-end Tequilas meant to be sipped
Enrique Acevedo traveled to Mexico to
meet the woman who was transforming the
way people drink tequila and making
history while doing it
we're right in the heart of tequila
Jalisco tequila is actually a town yeah
I was going to ask you because a lot of
people don't realize that tequila is a
town just like champagne or cognac in
France that's why I always like to start
here because then you realize the Beauty
and the Heritage that tequila has in our
country here in the highlands of Jalisco
in Western Mexico
that Heritage remains part of everyday
life
as ritual becomes routine
generations of Craftsmen called
himadores walk the Agave Fields wielding
long wooden handle blades called coas
used for centuries to slice the sharp
leaves of the Agave plants
foreign
as the leaves fall through the mineral
rich soil the plant's heart which takes
up to seven years to mature is revealed
a geometric mask called Pina which gets
cooked fermented and distilled into
tequila
I think our Craftsman can compete and
can be compared with craftsmans from
Japan from France from Italy from
England from anywhere in the world and
we're committed to exposing that
craftsmanship in everything we do and
that comes with you know focusing on
delivering two sipping Tequilas that can
compete with other shipping spirits and
that can showcase that tequila has 250
years of best practices it's as old as
any other spirit and just as popular
Tequila has become a global industry
worth over 13 billion dollars
think at the end what the consumer is
looking for is to be seduced by The
Taste and by the quality and that's
really our Focus we're trying to be part
of that Mexico that we grew up with you
know that sophistication that elegance
and that
richness and cultural energy and we want
to do it Through The Eyes of tequila
that's not necessarily the image people
have of Mexico in the U.S around the
world yeah absolutely and at the
beginning you know we went door by door
retail by retail restaurant by
restaurant and uh some people looked at
us and say this is not going to work you
know sipping tequila at that price point
how is you know that's not even possible
Bertha Gonzalez launched tragones in
2009 with her partner Bob Pittman the
chairman of I heart media since then
they have built a brand credited with
transforming how people drink tequila
now you see more people sipping tequila
in ashantangas and not so many people
just drinking it as a shark I know it
looks like a champagne fluid but it's
really that tequila official glass that
we use for professional tastings and
when I see people sipping on a tequila
in the right class and really going on a
journey of taste and enjoying it the way
that we designed to be you know enjoyed
that's really the Pinnacle of us as
producers Casa Draco race Blanco tequila
Casa dragones has become a celebrity
favorite catching the eye of Martha
Stewart this is my favorite tequila and
Oprah called Casa dragones and I keep
coming back to it because I really don't
know of a better tequila I remember I
was going to the airport and suddenly my
phone started to ring and it's like you
know they just launched Facebook live
and Cheryl Sandberg is interviewing
Oprah and she just went on and on about
Casa ragones it's called dragones it's
in a blue box and I was like Excuse Me
artist chefs and mixologists have
partnered with the brand to elevate
their own creativity
like Elena regadas named Latin America's
best chef in 2014 after opening the
award-winning Rosetta restaurant in
Mexico City
's profession it's her life as well and
in that sense I feel the same like I
cannot really you know say this is my
work and this is my personal life it's
it's really
what I do it's my passion and it's what
I love to do I feel better it's the same
regattas calls Gonzalez the ultimate
inspiration being a woman in in a place
like Mexico what it you know implies and
also hair in hair in being related to
agave and to Tequila that it used to be
and still is very a man's world in 2009
Gonzalez became the first official
female Maestra tequilera or Master
distiller in Mexico's history
in a country and an industry dominated
by men she has become the face of female
entrepreneurship once I started in the
industry I looked around it's like wow
there's not a lot of women here and I
think early on until today I really I
don't want my gender to Define my
potential I really want to have the
opportunity to be seen as a professional
in the tequila industry and I've always
LED through my work but gender
inequality is not the only challenge for
this industry as a category becomes even
more popular and sales grow so does
production limiting access to the raw
materials needed to make tequila so we
use the least amount of Agaves to
produce our tequila and then challenge
the processes to use the least amount of
water
and the least amount of energy possible
to be able to deliver extraordinary
quality and we think that that is truly
important for the next Generations that
are coming behind us
um because if we don't start tackling
these subjects now uh in the future we
may find uh bigger challenges for the
industry in general this could be up to
90 kilos wow
Gonzalez says she's in the business of
selling Mexico not tequila which
explains why the future of the
appellation is something personal to her
like it is for most Mexicans when we
were in the fields you said that tequila
is really part of Mexico's social fabric
what does that mean
so you know
definitely tequila is part of our social
fabric you see we celebrate with tequila
we cry with tequila we drink tequila
with our family we're doing tequila with
people that we're breaking up with
you know we we do everything with
tequila and I think that
um that's also something that people
internationally are looking for tequila
for taste for that beauty and the purity
of the spirit but also for its
personality you know that is very much
the Mexican personality that we're
exporting we're known for our
celebration we're known for our
livelihood we're known for our draw de
vivre so I think that that comes
together with a package of of drinking
tequila
so wait when you're when you're breaking
up thank you
picking up with someone you give them
tequila or you drink tequila but our
bosses do not trust us to have had a
drink in the last segment and to have
the tequila now maybe we're breaking up
everyone's breaking up nobody's breaking
up with us I did love when she said
we're not selling uh we're selling
Mexico we're not selling tequila yeah
yeah and we always love children I know
because Trailblazers yeah in this
country especially in certain States
Mexico gets a bad rap as a descendant of
Mexico I'd have to say
it shouldn't how about that sell it